hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of The Walking Dead Season
eight episode 5 the big scary you and
just when we thought we knew where this
show was headed though writers blow all
of our minds with a freaking helicopter
Wow
shouldn't that helicopter be a zombie
now that's how it works right I'm gonna
explain what this means plus all the
other questions you had after this
episode
this subtle callbacks the past episodes
some cultural influences and the deeper
meaning and real quick this video was
sponsored by movement watches and
sunglasses check out the description
below for more information or stick
around for the end for details on a
special offer ok let's get started with
our big question brought to us by Peter
on Twitter what is with the helicopter
ricksaw is it connected with the
helicopter from season 1 episode 1 now
what you guys actually asked us about
this so let's dive into it toward the
end of the episode Rick of course here's
the rotor blades of a helicopter looks
up and sees a helicopter gliding over
the trees now there are a few ways we
can look at this on one level yes this
is definitely a connection to the first
episode of the series season 8 so far
has been full of callbacks to season 1
the writers wanted to celebrate 100
episodes with these intentional winks I
think it's pretty cool in the pilot
episode when Rick rides a horse through
downtown Atlanta remember he hears a
helicopter looks up and sees a military
helicopters reflection on a skyscraper
starts to follow it but then runs into a
street filled with walkers now the show
never followed up officially on what
this helicopter was or who piloted it or
where it was headed some believe that it
was the military helicopter that we saw
in season 3 with that guy Wells found by
Michonne and Andrea and leading to the
governor or killing that guys unit it
all could have been that same helicopter
others believe that helicopter the pilot
could have been a hallucination by Rick
like that imaginary phone call he had
with Lori after she died that's an
interesting theory but I don't think
it's the case the law recall was adapted
from Robert Kirkman's comics it was a
tragic impressionistic moment that took
us inside Rick's chaotic grief as he
struggled to process Laurie's death in
that context a surreal elucidation kind
of made sense witnessing a military
helicopter while relatively mentally
stable is a different story so assuming
this helicopter is real to whom does
belong now one explanation is it belongs
to these saviors earlier in the episode
Simon suggested to negan to give Gregory
a chance at the hilltop and if it
doesn't work out quote take a flyer to
the place and kill everyone there and
some online it believes take a flyer
meant simon was suggesting to take a
helicopter fly over to the hilltop and
blast flight of the valkyries as they
rain hell on all those sorghum farmers
fun but not likely take a flyer is an
idiom meaning take a chance or roll the
dice
Simon is just suggesting to gamble by
trustee and Gregory with the worst case
scenario of exterminating the threat
also this doesn't exactly make sense
like why use a helicopter when you can
just drive over there and kill them just
as easily this is the hell top we're
talking about here it's Colonial
Williamsburg her deadliest weapon is a
spear so using an attack helicopter on
the hilltop would be like using an
attack helicopter on a hilltop also
Simon said take a flyer meaning the
Savior's would have several helicopters
so yeah this wasn't what Simon said your
app I mean while there was another line
from a savior the captain Regina who
proposes a plan to get a small crew out
of the sanctuary and come back with
something she called the fat lady now
that could be the Savior's code name for
that brownie and fifty caliber machine
gun that we've seen in recent episodes
that definitely be useful to clear that
Walker her hoard outside the sanctuary
or it could refer to this helicopter in
which case Regina could be proposing an
airlift evacuation now to me that sounds
like not the best plan either like
airlifting all the sanctuary workers and
their families on one helicopter that
would take forever and it would leave
them exposed to all the sniper fire that
they're worried about now I'm guessing
the fat lady is named after the phrase
in and over till the fat lady sings like
maybe in addition to classical music the
Savior's are into opera as well and
whatever weapon they would nickname that
that lady must be extremely loud and so
ending in some way so maybe that
browning machine gun or some armored
vehicle like a tank
yeah I'm gonna go a tank the other
explanation which i think is more likely
is that this helicopter belongs to a
different group altogether a new one
that we haven't seen it now to me this
is why Rick's seen this helicopter is so
exciting it returns us to that state of
mystery that we had in
early seasons like how large is this
world exactly has the military collapsed
entirely or are there still small units
of it like a 28 days later situation now
there is one group in the comics that
this could belong to that would be very
interesting for the show to bring in
this early but I guess it's kind of a
spoiler so if you don't want to know
anything if you haven't really read the
comics skip to this time okay so very
recently on Robert Kirkman's comic
timeline which are now way beyond the
show's current time period of the war
with negan a new mysterious community is
introduced they are called the
Commonwealth we really don't know too
much about them other than the fact that
they wear futuristic white armor almost
like stormtroopers from Star Wars and
they have advanced military-grade
weaponry now it's very possible that
they would have also their hands on a
military helicopter but considering
there's so much else in the comics
between this negan war and the
Commonwealth bringing in these guys this
early would be super premature so while
it may not be the most intriguing
possibility I think this helicopter is
just gonna belong to a group that is
completely new to show okay there was
another big question you guys were
asking about brought to us on Twitter by
Jojo was Gabriel bitten so one of the
final shots the episode shows us
Eugene visiting Gabriel in captivity in
prison in the sanctuary finding him
sweating bullets and shivering now this
is after Gabriel step through that crowd
of Walker's with negan covered in walker
guts so did Gabriel get bitten did any
of those Walker guts get in his mouth
my theory is no I rewatched that scene
over and over and over again and at no
point did we see him get bitten at least
on screen and while sure maybe he tasted
some of that Virginia Sunstein Walker GU
it's probably not making him sick here
that's right I think he is faking it
Gabriel tells you Jane that the Savior's
have Maggie's dr. Harlan Carson and I
think him flopping here is part of his
plan to break Carson out of the
sanctuary even return him to Maggie to
help deliver a baby Reid or maybe just a
memory of locking out his parishioners
is causing him to sweat like a Gabriel
in church now I'll address more
questions as we go but for now let's
move on to the ways this episode
connected to past episodes in our
segment callbacks in the opening scene
Simon brings gray
breakfast in bed including some sorghum
pancakes now this is a call back to
episode three of the season when Cal
accused Gregory at the hilltop of
stealing sorghum pancakes from a baby
yeah
shortly after this negan says to Gabriel
mask you something now this is a
callback to the season premiere when he
said mask you something Rick - Rick
outside in both cases these are
intentional nods by the writers - Shane
the mask
Rick meme later as a thank-you gift for
having his back earlier Eugene rewards
Dwight with a jar of pickles no those
pickles were the ones Eugene took for
himself when he got acclimated in the
sanctuary in episode 11 of last season
they were brined from cucumbers looted
from the hilltop groaned by his friend
former friends now I guess you could say
they were a symbol of this pickle man
brining into a new form shifting his
loyalty to the sanctuary and now by
giving these pickles away he's putting
the burden of shifting loyalties on
Dwight now a two-faced man caught in a
pickle of his own I know
mixing all kind of meanings for pickle
here Eugene also notices Dwight's
painted handmade soldier chess pieces
which he later realized this is a
red-handed clue of Dwight's treason now
the reason Dwight has had to freshly
paint these is we know that he has
expended these figurines in the past as
carriers of secret messages to his bro
buddy of Daryl so even without Eugene
seeing this matching paint stamp later
the fact that these figurines are
freshly painted to begin with already
should be a clue to us later notice how
Rick's hand is still wrapped when he
fights with Daryl now this is a
continuity detail and a callback to last
season when he impaled his hand on
Winston while proving his worth to the
scavengers why even bother now I like
how this wound persists as a reminder of
the mistake of trusting the trash people
at any point by the way it looks like
he's about to make that same mistake
next episode and Rick and Daryl's boy
fight results in the two of them
completely losing the loot that they
were fighting over with the truck
containing the machine gun in the
dynamite blowing up now this parallels
that episode back in season six when
Rick and Daryl finally scored a truck of
food and supplies but then thanks to
losing their cool they both ended up
watching sadly as their Lu
slip through their fingers I also like
how after this fight Rick grass to Daryl
chokeholds a legal [ __ ] and Daryl
spines yes it is this is a callback to
season 1 when Daryl attacked Rick and
Shane
Sharon put him in a chokehold and
illegal police takedown move that really
pissed off Daryl now and in speaking of
season 1 negan and Gabriel used these
same walker guts cover tactic to mask
the scent that Rick and Glen and used in
the first season and when they were
stuck in a similar Jam it's come up a
bunch of times throughout the series but
let's move on to some cultural
influences on this episode in our
segment under the influence which by the
way does this segment name even make
sense like it's kind of a drug thing but
I guess it kind of makes sense because
drugs like pop culture references can
influence you in a cool i opening way
but too many references kind of Rob's
you of your unique identity I'm thinking
about this to heart anyway let's start
with the way religion influences this
episode before the credits Gabriel tells
negan I'm here to take your confession
now of course this episode ends up being
somewhat of a confession by negan he
reveals that he had a wife that he
cheated on leading to his less than
sacred attitude toward marriage and that
he used to work with kids which is a nod
to his back story in the comics which I
won't talk about here in case the show
still plans to reveal that origin as a
big surprise but this episode also
becomes a confession for Gabriel as well
in order to induce a confession out of
Meegan he confesses his deepest darkest
secret locking his congregation out of
his church in a way this episode
compares these two flawed men asking us
which one of them is truly more godlike
Gabriel is more of a New Testament God a
God of forgiveness and redemption and
turning the other cheek meanwhile negan
is definitely an Old Testament God a god
of Wrath and fear in symbolic
demonstrations of power forcing people
to kneel before him this episode negan
bellows to his captains and to Gregory
that people are a resource which is a
twisted worldview that casts himself as
a savior somehow a force that the world
needs to save it from the abyss but none
of these characters are the true gods of
this world it turns out as this episode
ends with the reveal of others can just
soar over these petty conflicts this
potential deus ex machina completely
frames this war between negan and Rick
kind of like the rescue at the end of
The Lord of the Flies is this all-out
war really the end-all be-all we thought
it was gonna be will these new gods from
above
pick a side in this war this represents
such an interesting unknown quantity and
that brings us to the deeper meaning of
this episode titled the big scary you a
line from Gregory earlier who define
that you as the unknown fear of the
unknown is historically mankind's
greatest most powerful motivator it's
the source of so many things in our
world religion war racism the insurance
industry in Meghan's case he exploits
that fear with unpredictable extreme
measures perhaps his scariest quality is
how at any moment you're never quite
sure whether Megan's gonna bash your
brains in but that mystery also works
against me in this episode when he is
feared dead by his people a panic almost
arises in the sanctuary threatened me in
his very way of life from the inside
until his dominance once again gets
restored as a known quantity but the
arrival of this helicopter offering a
new dimension to this world
definitely threatens to oust him as an
even bigger scarier you okay let's check
in on this week's kill count we saw
really only two on-screen human
casualties this week Yago the savior who
drove the truck who bled out and then
was put down by Rick and another
insubordinate Savior that Regina killed
in the sanctuary but in terms of who
dropped the most bodies Gabriel tops the
list
he shot seven walkers and whacked
another over the head and considering
guys we don't really know how many
people were in his congregation Gabriel
could be responsible for the most deaths
of any one person on the Walking Dead
and let's talk about some predictions
for next week's episode episode 6 titled
the king the widow in Rick remember
those are the Savior's names for Ezekiel
Maggie and Rick the three leaders of the
kingdom the hilltop in Alexandria whom
the Savior's had been ordered not to
kill Rick will also apparently return to
the junkyard and tried to make some deal
with these scavengers that guy that we
saw whistling at the end of the episode
has similar close to the scavengers
remember they have also been known to
signal each other with whistles
after seeing such a massive defeat for
the kingdom last episode I could see
this
being the defeat for the hilltop there
may be more savior POWs than residents
of the hilltop and with Gregory there
things are really looking too good for
Maggie in the final three episodes of
this half season I'm predicting Rick's
forces might have to fall back to
Alexandria a question for you guys what
do you think the history was between
negan and Simon remember when Simon was
too vocal with his war strategy negan
snapped at him and asked if they were
backsliding now theory author out there
negan hinted to Gabriel that he had to
take sanctuary by force from previous
occupants who didn't have their [ __ ]
together I'm thinking Simon was one of
the higher-ups of that previous group
that Meegan's forces absorbed was Simon
initially struggling to play by negan's
rules but eventually getting in line
essentially what Rick could become if he
surrendered to negan let me know your
thoughts down below or tweet me directly
at da vas and follow new rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
our videos now a quick thanks to
movement for sponsoring this video
movement offers super stylish watches
and sunglasses that I wear all the time
they have this sleek minimalist design
not the too flashy to snag some walkers
or if you occasionally look like
Walker's I do you would be surprised how
well a classy movement watch or
sunglasses cleans you up so watch this
start at 95 bucks and sunglasses at 70
bucks and you can get them polarized you
know keep the Sun out of your eyes while
you're searching the skies for
helicopter get 15 dollars off today plus
free shipping and free returns just go
to MVM t.com slash new rockstars and
uses a code new rockstars when checking
out where you can click on the link in
the description come on guys let's go in
the movement cool and like and share
this video and subscribe to new
rockstars for deep analysis of all the
stuff that you love and also check out
my breakdowns from the first four
episodes of season 4 more theories and
insight into season 8 of The Walking
Dead and if you really love this channel
wanting to help us grow you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially Kenny
Smith thanks for watching guys bye